i hate when people say i'm brave you're
transitioning so young i don't tell you
how brave you are it's not that brave if
you're just being who you are there's
some really incredible moments you know
it being a teen rom-com
with a black trans girl as the leading
lady and love interest abu bakr likes
for you having someone land the lead
role with your background there's an
egyptian man who's just as fine as y'all
may be finer than some of us
and it's time honey to pull your hair
out scream it out the window for the
whole world to hear kind of deal
[Music]
wow no i'm stupid
making his directorial debut billy
porter is expanding the world of teen
romcoms
this story found me there was no
representation for me or anybody like me
you know and so i set out like i said
decades ago to fill that void
and so this piece
literally dropped out of the sky
anything's possible follows newcomer eva
rayne a trans teenager navigating her
senior year of high school all while
developing her first crush seeing
something like this when i was younger
it would have made me feel so much more
seen
it would have made me feel more
understood there are going to be so many
little trans kids in the smallest of
towns
who don't even have the language for who
they are yet who will see this and be
like oh
that's me we could live our own life or
spend the rest of our life wondering
what if what is it like moving from an
on-screen superstar to director
extraordinaire
well thank you for the extraordinary
part
it's been a dream of mine
it's everything i've ever wanted to do
indeed
it really truly is
[Music]